So, last week we visited the cork tree factory,
and also the harvesting.
You could see how the bark is taken off,
and processed in a factory into cork.
And, we actually used to have
three bigger cork trees on the land ourselves!
This one right here, still standing near the bottom yoga deck.
This is the only one that didn't burn down...
And, we used to have two other ones.
Here's another cork tree underneath my feet!
I'm walking on it right now,
because it collapsed a few months ago.
Makes you realize how big these things are,
so that you can just really walk on top of them.
But, here, you can see actually how it went.
So, it got hit by a fire, it got burned,
but kept being alive.
But, then, some windy day,
eventually the whole thing did crack and collapse...
Which is a shame, because it was a very
beautiful tree, close to Basekamp.
And, the third cork tree was actually located right here.
But, there isn't a tree anymore, because we actually used it.
And, this tree also was burned down,
and fell on the neighbors land.
He dumped it on our land, so we could use it.
But, it was there just rotting away...
So, last winter, we started to process it.
In this video, I'm going to show you what we did with it.
All the cool things we made.
And, we actually also are going to bake
some bread in our clay-made pizza oven.
So, yeah, welcome to new Project Kamp update!
Let's rewind!
The tree has actually already been here for a while.
And, with winter coming,
it slowly starts to rot away even more...
So, it's a good time to chop it.
We're going to make some little stools,
and a little table out of it, hopefully.
And, we could actually borrow João's chainsaw, which is super long!
So, we can really cut through
the thick parts.
Let's start.
So, here we have a nice selection of wood.
However, I did notice
a lot of them already started to rot...
Like here, it's got some mold on it,
some animals living in there...
So, we might want to scrape off the outer edges,
and make sure they don't rot anymore.
Here's the biggest part of the tree, and it's quite big!
Like, even this big chainsaw, as you can see,
it won't reach all the way.
So, here we can probably make a nice table out of it.
These two parts might look smaller...
But, they also come together here,
creating probably the biggest piece of it all!
Yeah, let's see, if we can chop them down
with that small chainsaw...
It took quite a while to go through this old dense wood...
But, we managed to cut out a few good pieces.
It's a rough cut and still needs some cleanup,
but lifting them up is impossible.
Way too heavy!
So, when our neighbor drove by,
with his front loader on this tractor...
We asked for some help, but they were actually also
too heavy for lifting with his tractor.
So, we had another creative way!
And, we dragged out all the pieces
that we thought would be somewhat useful.
Including this burned up piece, as a potential bench.
And, here's the heaviest one of them all!
We wanted to put them up for a while,
so they could dry up from that winter humidity they've been in.
And, just as a reference, to show how big they are,
here's one Spanish guy next to a cork.
And, as you can see,
the cork still has some bark around it.
If you want to know about what you can do with that...
Have a look at our previous video, where we visit a place,
where they harvest and process cork!
But, the cork isn't that usable anymore...
Since the bark already started to decompose,
and became a resource for another species...
Many mushrooms and worms in there.
It feels bad to take away their house.
But, it also feels bad, seeing all this valuable cork wood rot away.
It could still be used for many years!
So, after dragging all the pieces into Basekamp,
we let them dry for a while.
And after that, it's ready for cutting.
First up, a simple table from this big chunk.
Next up, this massive block.
And, the first step was to take off the bark...
And, looking at the tape measure,
it seems like actually two tables are hidden in there.
But, we can't cut it like this...
So, yeah, I guess we just flip it over and cut.
Easy...
And, finally, this rough one, like a bench sort of...
Well, with a few simple cuts,
it could probably be very useful.
So, after all of this,
we also had a few small pieces laying around.
We cut those up as a little pathway,
to keep your feet clean after a shower.
At this point, we're just looking for applications,
to make sure to cork doesn't rot away.
So, we cut a bunch of stuff...
Now, it's time to actually install it all in Basekamp.
Let me show you how we are
using them right now, a few months later.
So, this is the final result.
Now, we have a super cool bench!
This bench was chopped down, as you might have seen.
This was a bit sanded and oiled.
In front, we have this little, living table,
with some of big mushrooms here.
We can work a bit, drink some tea, whatever...
Just being in a space under the shade.
But even better, there's this space right here.
It's really under the shade, and it's perfect for meetings.
And this again, was also super sanded and treated,
like with some linseed oil.
So, that it resists a bit better to the weather.
And, Jerram created a few beautiful gardens here!
We expect in a few years that this is all covered up,
with jasmine or some climbing plants.
And, besides all of these places...
Tim also created another super beautiful space
in this direction, which is right there!
So, you guys might not really feel it,
but the temperature is super different.
Here, there is some breeze and it's under the shade.
This is just the ideal space to have some meetings!
Even better than on the deck,
because here the shade is from the trees.
So, it really cools down the area.
This is one of the bigger parts of the cork tree.
Also treated with oil, and sanded.
Some hammocks just to enjoy the siestas a bit,
when the heat goes up.
Tim has making some experiments with mimosa.
And, one of the experiments was this pull-up bar.
I personally wouldn't be able to do it and I wouldn't do it.
But, this is a super cool addition also to the land!
And, with the leftover bits,
we created benches all around the Kamp.
This one is a nice one.
Just next to the kitchen with a little heart.
Also, we chopped a few thinner bits,
that serve as steps we can go up.
Or, we can go down much easier.
Just follow the path up through the shower.
That actually leads us to the space
that we will clean up today.
Yeah, the cork bench is there,
or the cork table is there...
We will just clear all of this, put some wood chips,
and it's ready to go.
So, this section will be made by Coleen and I.
Coleen just arrived, and she’s a great addition to the team!
- Hello, I'm Coleen, and I'm here for two months!
- And, today, we're cutting some bushes,
and removing some nasty spikes.
Yes, we are!
Coleen, what are we doing now?
- So, we cleared up the area.
That means that the soil is very exposed...
Because, we took out of the soil and brambles.
So we're going to put wood chips on it.
And, it will allow the soil to be more conserved,
to not be too much in the heat...
And, also to have a comfortable mattress,
for our little feet, when we're resting.
- Oh, yeah!
So, the space is done!
It's super cool!
Now, this would be very shaded during the day,
and it will be super nice to hang out here.
Now, we took brambles away,
and we replaced it with woodchips.
So, much better for the feet.
We also took out a lot of big mimosas,
and at the moment, they're stacked on a big pile.
This pile is going to get chopped in pieces,
and put under the oven.
So, then, when we're going to do the bread,
we're going to use that wood.
And, now, we are off, because we're going to
watch a movie without you!
So, we should go! Bye, bye!
And, another ongoing project we have here,
is our research on breadmaking.
Making a bread yourself every now and then isn't too hard.
But, we're trying to find a way,
to realistically integrate it in our weekly routine!
Like, baking community amounts,
and using a wood-fired clay oven.
Yeah, it's quite a mission...
So, we have an ongoing research topic in our module.
Where you can find more information about it,
starting with burnt bread, and gradually improving.
Let me show you what the current
state of our baking process is.
- Hello, who are you?
Hello! Hey Felix!
I'm Ted, I'm from Netherlands, and I’m the vegan chef,
here at Project Kamp for about two months.
And, today, we're going to make sourdough bread.
We'll start with the first step,
and in the first step we'll be making a levain.
And, we'll explain to you what a levain is.
- So, you came after Agi, right?
Yes, I came after Agi.
- Okay, cool. Let's start!
Well, this is the starter for the sourdough.
So, that's a culture you keep on feeding.
It becomes wild yeast.
This starter is called Bert.
So, it has a name,
and you have to take care of it.
And, we're going to take two scoops of the starter
We're going to mix it with equal parts of
flour and water to make the levain.
Which will be the kickstarter, for making the sourdough bread.
So, that's going to make sure the sourdough bread
is actually going to ferment.
So, it doesn't come super precise,
but we take about two scoops of the sourdough starter.
We measured our amount of flour,
because we want equal parts of flour and water.
So, it's going to be a 100% hydration in your levain.
And, after that, you're going to play
with hydration in your dough.
But, with the levain, you want 100% hydration.
So, equal parts, water and flour.
Just getting tap water.
- How long are you going to wait
till you make the dough out of it?
So, I'm going to let this sit overnight.
It's going to ferment all the way.
It's going to double in size.
So, it's going to are going to rise and ferment all night,
and tomorrow morning, we can use it.
- So, we have here the starter already fed the levain?
And, later or tomorrow, we're going to do the dough?
- Yes, that's it!
So, Bert is going to live inside the fridge again.
We don't need to feed it constantly,
so we're going to let it go to sleep.
So, the fermentation and the yeast is less active in the starter,
so it's going to go back into the fridge.
So we covered the levain with the wet cloths
To keep it moist inside the bowl,
to make sure it doesn't dehydrate during the fermentation process.
Then, we see it tomorrow again...
- See you tomorrow!
So, it's the next morning
And, we're now have all the components
to make our sourdough.
So, first, we have the levain,
that we already made yesterday.
This fermented overnight and it became a lively culture!
Next to that, we have our flour of course.
It contains 80% of whole wheat flour and 20% white flour.
We have water, and we have salt.
We're going to mix all these ingredients together,
and make one cohesive dough.
So, let's do it!
Okay, so, we start with the levain.
You mix that in first.
So, we're going to mix in the levain.
And after that, the water,
to spread the the yeast throughout the water.
To make sure it's spread out in the dough,
in a later stage as well.
So, now, we pour in the water.
We give it a good stir.
So, that the levain mixes in with the water.
We can mix in the flour and salt.
- How much flour is that?
This is two and a half kilos of flour.
So, we'll make four loaves!
And, it's about 50 grams of salt,
so 2% of the weight of the flour.
- How long is it going to rest?
It’s going to rest for 4 hours.
I mean, normally, I would say 6 or 8 hours...
But now, I think 4 to 5 hours with these temperatures,
because it's 30 degrees plus here.
So, I would say 4 to 5 hours.
Now, the dough has risen, so it's like fluffy.
You can push it a little bit and bounces back.
So, we know it's ready.
- Full of air!
We roughly shape the dough,
but we make them in a baking tray.
So, they don't need to be shaped that much.
But, you do want to build up a little bit of tension...
On the top part of the of the dough,
so it will rise better once it's in the oven.
Ready to be baked!
- Add some water?
Yeah, some water to create some steam.
So, they don't directly seal,
so the crust doesn't directly form.
- How long do they bake?
They bake about 45 minutes normally, but often...
You have to look a little bit, and see how they develop...
Take them out, to see whether they are good...
So, 45 minutes at least, I would say,
but maybe up to an hour.
- You can hear it from here!
Bread dinner! I like it!
All right, so, that was it for this video!
Thank you guys for watching!
If you already want to see the next video,
make sure to support on Patreon!
Or not, and we'll see you again next week.
Same time, same channel! Bye!